this woman is being forced to endure
what no parent wants to go through she's
waiting outside the hospital hoping to
hear news of her daughter
the teenager went to one of the churches
attacked on Easter Sunday and hasn't
been seen since we kept calling her
after we heard of the incident but there
was no response we didn't hear from her
even in the night that is why we came
here first thing in the morning for
others the certainty of knowing brings
no relief as the scale of the tragedy
starts to sink in many are unable to
contain their grief most of the dead are
Sri Lankan many including at this church
north of the capital were children
dozens of foreigners were also killed
among those who lost their lives our
nationals from the US Britain Turkey
India China Portugal and Denmark
alongside the sadness there is also
disbelief and a growing sense of outrage
this is a very sad moment this is a very
currently attack and it's it's not just
an attack it's a very gross gruesome
attack on humanity in the aftermath of
the carnage Sri Lanka is a nation in
shock and looking for answers well with
the people of Sri Lanka still reeling
from these heinous acts and trying to
make sense of what just happened let's
get you the latest from the capital
Colombo a journalist
Jamilah Nasheed Budin joins us from
there she's on the line I believe Jamila
we understand that security forces
initiated a controlled blast does this
mean that the threat is still around yes
just a short while ago security forces
donated a bomb in capital Colombo which
was in close proximity to the Anthony's
Church where the first bomb went off on
Sunday it was a very loud explosion and
people started panicking and ran for
shelter just a short while before that
there were 87 explosives which were
found both in one of Colombo's main bus
stations and this last night the Air
Force found another bomb business
keeping in close proximity to the
National to the International Airport
and throughout the day we have been
hearing reports that the explosives have
been found hidden in vehicles abandoned
vehicles in the road roadways so
definitely the threat is still on it's
far from over
okay yeah so the threat remains what can
you tell us about this little-known
domestic terror group that which is
being blamed for the coordinated attacks
yes
so when Sri Lankan Health Minister Dr
artificial Arachna announced today
afternoon that a local Muslim radical
group called the National towie Tomas
was behind these attacks
this was a little new to all of us even
even I being a journalist it was a bit
new to me because I have not heard this
name before there had been isolated
incident which were caused by some
radical Muslims early in the year but it
was this group which were responsible
for that is yet to be certain ito this
is a new group which we are hearing at
the moment is there a history of violent
Muslim militants in Sri Lanka yes in
fact in February there was an incident
where some radical Muslim youth had won
and vandalized some Buddhist statues in
a town called Mandela not too far from
capital Colombo however those who are
responsible for those attacks were
arrested there had been isolated
incidents which have been going on even
before that but these are just a very
handful of incidents now obviously the
other thing that is causing a lot of
concern is that there has been a
complete breakdown in communication with
within the Sri Lankan government the
attacks were flagged but nobody acted on
it just how functional is this
government and will anybody be held
accountable for this serious failure
well I am not sure whether if anyone
from the government will be held
accountable for what has happened but
yes we are disappointed as a nation we
are disappointed to learn of the fact
that the police had received prior prior
information of a possible terrorist
attack and there was a severe mass
miscommunications between the prime
minister between the Cabinet of
Ministers and the president and the
state intelligence and the police and
nobody seems to have coordinated
business formation with each other and
this has costed us very heavily today
there have been reports which have come
out that ever since the October 26
constitutional crisis we are President
Maithripala Sirisena sacked prime
minister which a messenger and appointed
the former president as
Prime Minister there have been reports
that there have been internal conflicts
within this government against the
president so it is a very sad situation
we are seeing at the moment I mean of
course a lot of people know that
Sri Lanka has had a very painful recent
history can you very briefly explain
what happened and where is the country
right now yeah so basically 2009 Sri
Lanka defeated terrorism after 30 years
of a conflict and 2019 meet we were
gonna celebrate 10 years since terrorism
left our shores but unfortunately this
attack happens on Sunday and people are
now scared and fear where the Terrorism
has returned back to our country how we
are going to proceed forward as a nation
is yet to be seen because we all are
still recovering from the deadly blast
but a lot of changes need to now be made
and security definitely needs to be
tightened with maximum level going
forward alright journalists Oh Jamila -
ma Gina reporting from the four Lankan
capital colombo thank you thank you very
much that was Jamila national dean
editor of news and Asia speaking to us
from Colombo did have a chorus for an
image as well is also in Colombo at the
site of one of Sunday's attacks she sent
us this update in Colombo one of the
places where blasts occurred on the
Sunday of Easter eight different
explosions all across Colombo as well as
in other locations in Sri Lanka behind
me you can see the shangri-la you can
see the restaurant where the blast
ripped through we were not able to gain
access to one of the main churches which
was hit because it has been cordoned off
and the city remains tense traffic has
started up again there was a curfew from
6:00 p.m. last evening Easter evening up
until 6:00 a.m. this morning and while
traffic has resumed locals here tell us
there it is far lower than it usually is
for this time of the day for this kind
of a Monday and the streets of course
are tense one ministry
person has named a group the group
itself has so far not come out to claim
responsibility but ministry officials
are coming out and saying that another
curfew will be imposed to night from
8:00 p.m. till 4:00 a.m. a national
emergency is also expected to set in
tonight and tomorrow is has been
declared the National Day of Mourning or
at least 290 deaths have already been
reported dozens of these have been
foreigners Sri Lanka remains stands and
the country is in mourning but let me
now draw in PR guru von pati Rana she is
a South Asia region researcher with
Amnesty International welcome to yagi
now as we said one minister said a local
radical group was behind these attacks
in Sri Lanka has there been a history of
tension between the Muslim and Christian
minorities in the country not to my
knowledge no there has been a lot of
tension between religious community so
that's between the Buddhists and Muslims
as well as the Buddhist Buddhist meaning
not all of them it's mostly the
extremist groups against the Christians
as well especially the Avengers but this
is what's appearing now is sort of a new
nexus between the Christians and the
Muslims it's not something we're
familiar with well but this is the worst
violence in Sri Lanka since the end of
the civil war ten years ago how much of
a setback is this for a country which
had only recently began healing after
decades of violence I think healing is a
difficult one because I think successive
governments even following the end of
the war hasn't been doing sufficient or
an acceptable level of post-war
reconciliation in terms of truth in
terms of justice getting answers to
disappeared so those those issues are
still being carrying on but in the midst
of that I think a lot of the people have
just started forgetting what it was like
in the Warriors violence and this is an
scale of this it's actually
reminding us of what it was like between
before 2009 and it's really shocking and
it comes as something that's really
surprising at this point now in fact
there's some discussion that political
tensions within the government between
the Prime Minister and the president led
to some communication failures in
intelligence ahead of these attacks we
had one correspondent talked about a
sense of betrayal that people are
feeling what do you make of that that
that seems to be what's coming out
especially since the prime minister's
statement last night where he said that
he has he nor the Cabinet of Ministers
were made aware of these threats that
have apparently been reported earlier
but that seems to be a fair assessment
and I think the tensions between the
president and the Prime Minister have
been coming to I mean we've been
experiencing that since last year and we
saw that this especially in October when
the president actually remove him to the
sitting Prime Minister and appointed a
new one so those tensions have been
ongoing it's hard to say certain if that
plays a role in this but it's early
appears that way right Thea Reuven Patty
Rana from Amnesty International thank
you very much